you have uh amassed this really cool
body of work you're a terrific
Storyteller and um a terrific you make
these these oneman shows that are um
beautifully constructed than and you are
not so I want to take a second here and
and and acknowledge what you've done
which is you are not I have so much
respect for standup but what you do it
feels like you've carved out really
something quite unique
and I think that's that's my highest
compliment to musicians and comedians is
when I say this person found something
they work they they worked hard in the
dark alone they figured it out and they
came out with something that's truly
them and I think you've done that like
people you have a this huge following
which is people want to want to hear
Mike bigia tells stories that are very
personal to him no I appreciate it it's
I'm lucky I just you know I'm doing a
new tour called please stop the ride
it's like a whole new hour and it's uh
and it yeah it seems like people still
want to see the next show you know it
it's weird every time I always talk
about this with my friend Jack antinoff
who's from bleachers great musition and
we've been friends for like 20 years
we're both touring acts and like when
you put a tour on sale you find out if
anyone still cares yeah you know what I
mean and it's like and so it's exciting
that I've made these yeah like you're
saying like I made these things that and
it's kind of by accident that I made it
specific it's really just because I'm
like I'm really interested in plays and
I'm really interested in movies and
drama and then also I'm really
interested in standup and along the way
I started working with a theater
director Seth beish and I just I started
working with theater producers and all
at a certain point it just became a
thing like it wasn't an overnight thing
it just and at a certain point like my
probably my biggest break was like in 20
8 um Nathan Lane agreed to be present My
Show Off Broadway Sleepwalk with Me
which is the first one of these and that
was helpful because it like sort of put
me it made people show up and and think
it's a piece of theater as opposed to
just writing it off as stand up little
to have Nathan Lane true no but but like
to have Nathan Lane's imprint I mean he
is uh he's a gold standard he's a gold
standard and so for Nathan Lane to say
you all need to pay attention to Mike
biglia I mean to give yourself credit
you've also had you are uh You' you've
had a fascinating life uh you've had a
very interesting life you've had a lot
of um health issues and you've been
really honest about them and they are
quite dramatic and these stories you
tell are riveting I mean they're really
like and to the point where I mean I
remember like the the highest compliment
I can pay to someone this sounds
terrible but Los Angeles is a very
specific place and Theater in LA to get
to theater in La you need to it's not
like New York where you say I want to go
check out that show I'm going to walk 15
blocks this way and go see the show I
heard that you were doing your show and
and Greg Daniels and I were talking
about it and we decided let's go down
and and and see Mike biglia do his uh do
his show so we uh we drove to downtown
Los Angeles to see your show and I
remember thinking as I'm driving into
downtown LA this is
commitment cuz it's like a 40 minute as
far Odyssey and you feel like it's like
Lord of the Rings like there's different
tests along the way and uh we lost the
ring for a while but we got it back and
we crossed the river and we we you know
and then finally we ended up at this
wonderful theater and we saw you and you
were worth it definitely worth the trip
oh thanks yeah it's weird how yeah it's
weird how you end up where you are and
then also like you were talking about
the Nathan L thing it's a little bit
like with Lauren Michaels with you with
late night yeah cuz like I remember when
that happened in the 9s when they were
like and the new host is a writer who
you do not know who's replacing also to
put it in context I always I used to I
did this bit once uh on Charles Groen
show but he was like now what was it
like when you replaced Letterman and I
was like what is it what was it like I
said
imagine I can't imagine I said imagine
um imagine that because you know
Letterman 1993 and this is back when
there were very few comedy Gods you know
that it's a very different landscape now
but he's this he's the biggest icon in
comedy and and Carson's retired and so
it's like it's Letterman in in my world
and then uh imagine them saying uh in uh
in baseball you know Joe dagio is now
retiring today ladies and gentlemen
gentlemen gentlemen gentlemen he is
leaving the field forever forever
forever forever goodbye Joe deio
greatest Legend in Yankee history
history history history but don't worry
ladies and gentlemen gentlemen gentlemen
Here Comes his replacement 19-year-old
chip
Whitley and like a bat a Bat Boy comes
running out like hi everybody I'm going
to disappoint you for a while while
while but don't worry worry worry if you
stick with me with me with me after
about four four or five years years
years you'll grow to love me love me
love me and that's what it felt like and
that's exactly what it was it was
crazy yay boo y lots of fun to do if you
like it Hol yeah and if you don't but
uh but um it was it was absolute Madness
but it's so funny that you remember that
but fan like people that are into our
stuff now or like the podcast whatever
and people in their 20s they have no
idea yeah they just think oh you you're
like Mickey Mouse you were just always
around like no no I'm no there was a
there was a time when it was really
rough yeah like I and I feel like the
thing that's happened this Show's called
the old man in the pool and by the time
people yeah I'll say it's on Netflix now
it's called the old man in the pool cuz
it will cuz it's out right now it's out
right now and I want I had a fear about
it which was I was like the vision was I
want to do a show that's that's 90
minutes of jokes and stories about death
because I feel like if we you know face
the thing that we're more scar most
scared of in in my case death um that
there's a catharsis for that for
everybody potentially and I did have a
fear of like oh I'm going to go out with
this and then some people are going to
be if they're going through you know
sorrow or dealing with deaths of people
close to them are going to have a bad
it's going to have a bad
effect and it was the opposite like
literally the people who would come up
to me like when I was doing it in LA
like I remember like this woman came up
to after the show and she was like I
recently lost some people in my life and
I lost my dad and a bunch of people and
and tonight when I was in the audience
like I felt like I was laughing with my
dad and it was like and genuinely like I
feel like that's the thing about being
in my 40s that I did not expect first of
all I didn't expect to be doing comedy
in my 40s somehow like in my 20s and 30s
and didn't anticipate that it would
continue somehow but I feel like the
thing that I've I've started to realize
is like oh it really is about them it's
about the audience it's about their
experience and if like if you can get
people to that point that's why I'm
excited that it's on Netflix now because
it's like oh well maybe it'll have that
effect with the you know the hundreds of
millions of people who who are able to
get to Netflix that's been my Discovery
but you know the thing is uh like like
in your it's funny cuz
to and this is a compliment again hard
to categorize you because you are very
funny and you are a comedian and you are
doing stand-up comedy but it's also not
stand-up comedy because you're telling
stories and we've talked about this
somewhat I know and you mentioned your
mom I know your mom was a major
influence on you because like my parents
she comes from this Irish storytelling
uh Trad and I just knew that I I grew up
in a similar kind of situation where
telling stories and and and being able
to make something that happened to you
funny was sort of just a way of life
it's how you it's it's how you grew up
it wasn't even thought of as a Prof as a
possible profession right yeah it's like
it's definitely not I mean I grew up I
was at of Worcester I didn't even grew
up I was at of Boston like people don't
even understand when I explain where I
live like central Massachusetts they're
like why would any anyone live there in
the middle yep the middle in shury
Massachusetts which I love and I just
went back there recently I love it but
it's also like no one in the town
thought Show Business wasn't a job that
anyone even had right I it was an
outrageous thought uh but uh yeah I feel
like even when I go home now it's like
and my mom's a great Storyteller you
know and my my siblings you know my two
sisters Gina and Patty my brother
they're a riot and like the most fun is
my wife always comments on this is is
that when I'm home it's not the
dinner the Christmas dinner that's funny
it's like the 11 12 at night 1:00 a.m.
sitting around the kitchen aisle kitchen
yeah kitchen and just telling stories
about kids you grew up with and what's
going on with everybody and what's this
person up to and like and that's like
I'm getting choked Ed up even saying
it's like weirdly that's my favorite
thing to do yeah be with people you love
and just tell stories about things right
but I think you've been done a really
good job of replicating
that that there's an alchemy that
happens specifically around the kitchen
island or for us I can I I I still see
it when I go home and my parents are
still uh with us it's so funny melany I
was last time I was talking to him
and I mentioned that my dad is 94 and he
said I think it's I forget how he said
it because his diction is so perfect his
word choice but he just said I think
it's like something unseemly or silly
that a man your age still has his
father and I was
like no but it was I could kind of see
like oh come on Conan you're ancient and
you're saying I just saw my dad that's
ridiculous but um but I I kind of knew
what he was saying but uh I think he
said was he like it's not dignified it's
almost not dignified like oh stop that
like oh stop that Conan that's
ridiculous but uh I I go back and see my
folks and it's the same house I grew up
in in Brookline and there's that there's
that Round Table that's still there and
I'm sitting at that same table and all
that stuff comes back which is oh this
is where I really cut my teeth this is
where I everything else
uh has been a refinement yeah of that
you're just refining and adjusting and
and but but the basic concept of how it
all works happens around your kitchen
table